okay um so the last video on the usid
Wasa kiten
nugget um some things to understand and
again I'm using these techniques to kind
of broaden what we're talking about to
address what other questions people have
in the
community um so as I watch that video it
comes back to this in my opinion and
this is one of the markers that
distinguishes sensin iido from other
iido that's out there okay uh in
particularly what makes it
Marshall uh or or allows it to function
martially um those tactics contained
within
Kona okay uh so let me just review this
stuff okay uh here on the top line we
want to understand uh the Kinesiology
behind balance okay okay the official
word is
equilibrium what makes up balance what
makes up equilibrium what makes up
posture okay this is very important when
it comes to a throwing art because we're
trying to throw people uh from their
given posture out of their given posture
and we're trying to take their balance
so to speak okay a couple things here
that we have to remember aside from
equilibrium means balance um um is that
equilibrium is always dynamic in the
human body and especially in the human
body martially speaking so I'm going to
give it to you here static so that we
understand the elements but we must
never forget that it is always Dynamic
that really plays a role when it comes
to fight applications okay so the
elements of posture or upright position
balanced person um are three fold uh one
you have the center of
gravity and two you have the Bas of
support so the Bas of support are the
contact
points um in this case let's say the
feet so one foot and the other foot the
contact points of the
body on the
ground and the area in between so the
area in between my feet all of that
makes up the Bas of
support then you have a theoretical line
it doesn't really exist anatomically you
can't point to it um from the center of
gravity perpendicular to the surface
upon which the base of support is so in
this case if I was standing on the
ground these are my feet the line of
gravity is perpendicular from the center
gravity to the map okay and as long as
as the line of Gravity Falls within the
base of support anywhere between my feet
or on my feet you will have equilibrium
you will maintain balance that person is
going to remain upright okay so that's
what we have to understand generally on
what's going on we're dealing with this
organization okay but how do we address
disequilibrium in sension
so we have to first understand what is I
then now I have never seen this phrase
um in English I refer to it as the
seized
Center but I use this phrase
because seizure is
metaphorical and the Japanese addresses
it
better so II is
communion of what of the
tonad and that is what leads to this
seizure this sense of my center part is
being seized someone else is in control
of it okay and this is the
seed of kazushi and this is what is
missing in iido everywhere else and I'm
sorry for those of you who still believe
that your Shan or this Shan or you felt
it um that you had some Center to Center
connection with
your noget and I'm sorry I just don't
buy it I've never seen it it's something
different I for example I've
demonstrated uh quite clearly in my
opinion that usually what's going on is
linking which is just a pulling the skin
suit um the bones and the and the skin
and stuff like that that eventually SE
uh affects the center of gravity that's
not
ionen okay um ionen can happen without
any movement at all right at touch so if
you what you would look for I guess is
as soon as you see my ukas either touch
me here or I touch them you kind of see
them experience this kind of contraction
that's happening um it's also what you
see when I share the taiichi videos
because it's just Silk Road Eastern Silk
Road uh understanding of the yin yangong
aspects at an alchemical or slash
energetic level you always see that kind
of happening okay and I'm sorry it's
just not in iido it's not in iido after
after ensei you just don't see it
anywhere
okay um but that is what we do at touch
so it looks on the surface that
everything is still in place and the
body remains upright but something has
changed in the seizure of the center in
this model where the person is upright
the person has control of their Center
and they position it within their base
of support and they remain
upright here they don't have control of
their Center but for the time being it
is left within the base of support and
so they remain upright but they don't
have control of their center that is
very very important okay because we're
going to do something with
that we are going to take this control
of the center as the seed as aiten is
the seed of
kazushi and then we want to understand
something uh and this is the important
part on what makes sensin iido martially
viable and what makes ferite iido modern
iido not martially viable
okay so we are going to generate
disequilibrium along loss of balance a
loss of posture
kazushi but we do it in the following
way we take the C's Center
gravity and we move
it out from on top of the basis support
so the line of gravity the theoretical
line from the center of gravity to the
surface on upon which the base support
rest is going to fall outside of the
basis support here are my feet and the
area between my feet and as we move this
center of gravity the C center of
gravity one way we always move the Bas
of support another way the opposite way
okay that way as we mentioned in the
last video when we generate the Topsy
Turvy effect we kicked out the legs one
way and we made the head go the other
way okay and as we did that is we tilt
the
body sending the center of gravity up
towards the head as it starts to lean
here's the head and the base support
goes the other way the person always
falls that is innate in the x pattern
and I would ask you to understand it as
a
direct generation of loss of balance of
disequilibrium what modern feride iido
does is a
passive generation of disequilibrium and
the difference is they accelerate UK so
what they do is they
leave this basis support under here and
they attempt to by linking or pulling on
the skin suit or getting out of the way
move the center of gravity outside of
the Bas of
support that would look like
this let's say here's the Bas of
support the area in
between they don't have a c
Center they just have a center gravity
and then they
try to move
it this
way until
eventually they get
it somewhere over
here outside of the Bas B support so the
line is
here line of
gravity center of gravity and now the
person falls now what happens though in
real
fighting is the person the opponent
always just moves their base of support
with you moving their line of gravity
and they don't
fall they reposition they change levels
they Counterattack okay and so
acceleration or passive generation of
dise equilibrium just does not function
martially it doesn't Okay so hence
why I'm opposed to acceleration throws
and I want to see x pattern throws I
want to see the two main elements of
equilibrium move apart from each other
and unable to move back towards each
other okay so let's get into that in
this ushida kiten net now all right um a
couple things to bring into the
technique uh because I have to move the
center of
gravity and the line of gravity outside
the base of support I I have to do that
directly I have to do it I have to move
it until it's out of the base of support
I don't want to to push it in the
direction of going
outside and then inertia or acceleration
continues it past the Bas of support
okay so let me we we bend them over in
kiten n and so right now her center of
gravity is in her
hot but as she starts to lean over the
center of gravity travels up the body
and the line of gravity moves forward
see
okay and we keep going and that line of
gravity is now somewhere around here now
if I
keep taking her this way eventually it
will pass outside her toes and it'll
generate the loss of balance
okay now if that's all I do so let's say
I directly take the line of gravity so
I'm going to push so that my hand passes
her toes my hand will pass her toes
okay that's an example of me directly
causing that to
happen an
acceleration is
me pushing to her toes or towards her
toes but not directly going past it this
is what I'm trying to do
and you can generate a little more and
it'll work okay but as you can see in
each case she didn't do a forward roll
because she can reposition her basic
support back under so I will do the
direct method where my hand itself
passes her basis support and you can
watch that she's just stepping under it
and regains her
balance even on the acceleration one she
can do the
same they don't do forward rolls
okay now if I stop her body from moving
forward and I do the
same moving her
forward she will eventually fall out
okay if if I take her legs in the
opposite
direction so here I'm still trying to
bring her Center gravity upper body line
of gravity outside her base support if I
take her legs like a reow so that her
legs are going I won't do the top part
but her legs are going
by now she's going to fall every time so
you doing the same thing she's going to
fall every time no athleticism is going
to let her bring her legs back
underneath her okay so that's a kind of
understanding of what we're talking
about so let's focus in on the
arm we're kind of in this
position and we have this arm in Kaiten
nag and this is very very common
that I just
accelerate the arm let's have it more
like the technique so let's bring your
right foot forward there you go okay we
here like
this and you kind of give that cue to
the
UK
okay there's something to notice here
this this is the shoulder
joint and there's a lot of
slack as the contact point at the wrist
travels without manipulating the center
of gravity and that's the line of
gravity so I'm here like this and the
joint is
absorbing all of the
force and I have not affected the line
of gravity at all and you will not
affect it until on this on this path
that all the ferides take you will not
affect it and I'll just have her tell me
when it gets tight so the viewer on the
camera can feel it
okay so now it's running out of slack
and now at this point as I go you can
see that it will start to manipulate the
center of her
body
okay but as I said equilibrium is
dynamic and so what if I stay on this
fedorite
trajectory as she starts to turn I got
to hold her and she's got to tell us so
here's where that tension is that she
felt but as she starts to turn her body
you can see that the relationship
changed on the shoulder so come back
look where I am to her shoulder joint
but as she starts to roll I'm not in
that anymore stay where you are right
now here's where that tension is do you
see it's so you
can't here no direct effect on the line
of gravity till about here and as she
starts to roll it starts to go off do
you see so now I'm not directly causing
equilibrium it's passive equilibrium
okay but usually what happens is the
she's going to roll so scoop back the
the D Pony UK feels that and that's
their cute to go but no one does that in
a fight okay so as she's trying to turn
my my hand around and she's trying to do
that and I feel my balance and I regain
my
posture as that as that slack goes off
so here she is let's control my head
here let's change feet okay so as she
starts to go there's no tension there go
back so from here to there there's no
effect on my center of gravity until she
hits the joint tension there it is and
as I start to turn it comes off again
and I'm back in to
fight that's what everyone will do
that's
fighting
so there is a couple ways is where you
get the arm
tension it's not
here there's too much slack there you
have to figure out where that
is so if you pay attention when I'm back
here no arm tension in the shoulder no
direct manipulation of the
center if I come out here you can see
how more readily that is
okay and usually we do this technique
because I'm going to turn her so for
example I'm bring her head this way and
that generates more arm tension as we're
coming along and then I move
into that Yin spot where she gets it
back so I would be moving this way okay
and I stay there as best you can and now
there's arm tension here affecting her
Center this
way we'll do it one more
time so to get that arm tension The
Joint has to the hand has to be above
forward of the shoulder when the hand is
back of the shoulder there's no arm
tension when the hand is above the
shoulder towards the head side of the
shoulder you will get the arm
tension more readily okay and in the
technique that I did when we do this I
try to always keep the hand north of the
shoulder and then that joint will not
take the slack out of the control of her
Center but that is not kit knet okay but
that's the only time I ever used a hand
to manipulate the
center in the
technique we uh let's move
for in the
technique we
use this fact that she is uh step back
with your right foot that she's coming
around this way
and we use up the
joint to
project this way
boom and so that is right
here and just to do it
externally it is
a direct app ation of displacing
them this to there change feet
okay and you have to displace her past
her Bas of support so if I only go like
that her line of gravity never traveled
outside her Bas of support your
projection must move her Center outside
that
foot okay so when you're doing the
[Music]
throw and this is why my ukas don't
roll right where they're
at they find their roll somewhere out
there because the center got projected
past the Bas of support
okay um
if the
UK absorbs like she's even absorbing is
it's scary
okay she's
absorbing you follow it to the next
contact point which is
here I don't come back up to the arm so
I'm in the center absorbs now I'm here
and then the same thing my my
hand must go past
her Bas of support my hand itself I
don't just do that my hand itself goes
past that
foot the distance that I that I have to
travel to get past that foot gets
shorter as we're
on the curve okay so as we're on the
curve here it's very short to get past
that foot in the technique so on the arm
control let's do a
sha
around boom okay and here we are on this
technique boom it's right here project
past her Bas
support I don't do again
this okay so use the r use the CQ
projection to directly send the line of
gravity outside the Bas of support all
the way not accelerate it towards being
outside the Bas of
support okay the next thing I would want
to address is the use of the
cloth um
we already know I can't double pivot I
can't double weight and so we already
know that
I not only does that mean that I don't
turn both feet but my line of gravity is
Never
Off one foot in the middle of my two
basis supports on a rotation so I I
never t con like that that that never
happens I do the turn on one foot and
then this foot steps straight back
that's ten con okay so I never do this
that maneuver that
ruding that double weighting double
pivoting that line of gravity in between
the two base support elements is just
modern
iido it does not function
martially because it cannot overcome any
resistance which you're going to face in
a
fight
because it will the oppositional Force
to what you're trying to manipulate will
eventually cut through your basic
support elements on the shikaku line in
japanese and it will pull you off
balance and if it pulls you off balance
inversely that means you won't have the
positional Integrity required to
displace their Mass okay
because modern iido are D ponies and
they take any
Q that's where you see that it
functioning because it's not actually
being used
to displace an opponent even to throw
them okay it's not actually being used
so common ones and myid don't know this
so uh just kind of understand that so
common ones for example is is I do K
Ash I
withdraw from here and move my
claw into the
power
okay and so as she let's say she wants
to go that way you want to resist and
pull that way okay she feels the power
of the clo okay that's what she feels
like I'm very strong there okay very
powerful she also
feels the grounding foot so as she tries
to resist the throw she she feels that
leg
grounding then the qua
moves and you have the
power in feride iido start
over you you're going to do a ten con
there okay get something here and I ten
con into the
Thro and we'll go kind of slow so you
can see where I will lose my my power so
she's going to again resist she's trying
to go straight ahead fighting the throat
okay and so here she's going to feel
that front foot but as I start to turn
around she's still trying to go that way
then I start to lose the Integrity of it
I I think you could just walk forward
right about
now but no one experiences that because
the UK always has the CU here's the que
and then they go they go ahead and throw
themselves okay so same thing here on
this technique
we came
under that's my que you see I
can do the
10 okay so let's put the other foot
back okay and I have
to bring her forward into the throwing
angle okay so she's going to
resist what she's going to feel first is
my grounding
here where I do this onto this foot and
now when I'm on this foot then this foot
can move so I'm on that foot okay and
now we're here she's still trying to
pull that way she will feel the quaw
power when I'm here like this and she
doesn't want to come forward and I do
that ten con I cannot pull her forward
I'm not in position so she's trying to
walk away that way walk
away okay and as I start to ten con I'm
going to lose some power
okay that is demonstrating that I can't
throw bigger people I can't throw
resisting people I can't throw stronger
people this why it doesn't function
martially okay what usually
happens here when you see the ten conon
is this just the cube so she gets the
CU and so I can
go and do that tank con but you could
have done
anything right so here like this you're
going to roll take the
CU you could have done that it had as
much you could have done that none of
those function
kinesiologic okay so when we do the
technique boom
it's leg and glute power boom
and qua power that's all I can go don't
rotate don't
rotate
boom this is it that's all you
get okay to put the
power of
rotation in L claw M that's
what is
that it's in C hole so when I do c hole
my
quaw
turns that's where the throw is that's
as far as I can
go don't turn your waist this is it
got to get the head you got to think
ahead
got to control the
head watch your
foot and then don't don't push the head
the head comes around
head comes
around the head comes
[Music]
around switch you n
is
[Music]
for e